what's up party people welcome to honest
trailer commentaries the show where we
talk about our show that talks about
other movies and shows I'm Joe star
let's stay in Merle I have my headphones
on and I'm just rolling with you're just
ready to go ready Harris I feel like I
should put my headphones on now so
there's some parity
we're with you solidarity guys Spencer
is still a dad today we're talking to
the dead Wow
yeah yes Kanye was said 18 years for the
next 18 years until his child is in
college no that's how it works that's
how paternity leave works yeah I think
so
thank God we have such in progressive
countries no 18 years of paternity leave
this week we're talking about a Robin
Hood which Dan yeah she's my baby oh I
wonder this dude I want I walked out of
the theater saying we're doing this for
not the views are gonna be low and I
don't care baby cuz this is honest
trailers was made for ya
you know it was not made for honest
trailers Lego Batman which a lot of
people have already been like wears like
a Batman Lego Batman is an honest least
honest trailer about movie of all time
yeah yeah movies that are intensely like
self-referential I don't know if people
realize like if it's already really meta
it's very hard for the honest trailer
because the movies kind of already
pointing out its flaws yeah called Ryan
Reynolds twice there's a reason why
because we wrote half a Deadpool trailer
just won his own movie yeah yeah there
was a sliver a brief tiny sliver that we
were gonna get Will Arnett way back in
the day way to do Lego Batman that did
not happen that was the only way we were
ever gonna do a Lego Batman trailer as
if Lego Batman just did it he realized
it would be a huge mistake yeah come on
but so we're not Lego Batman and that's
why so we're doing Robin Hood which I
was I was so glad you made me watch this
cuz this is so bad it's such
a perfect example of everything
misguided about movies today know what a
property no one cares about you
ripping off Christopher Nolan yeah it
was so clearly like hey Robin Hood let's
do a rabbit a movie without even like a
take on right it's just the Robin Hood
you already know again no forget what
you think you know yes it's exactly what
I think you know except for the rampant
historical errors but you sure boy no
but but it's the exact Robin Hood legend
you've seen in every other movie that
does Robin but again lon
forget what you forgot or what you've
already seen I mean I have forgotten the
Ridley Scott Robin Hood like I saw it
with Russell Crowe I couldn't tell you
any I never actually saw it everyone was
like no and so I just never I only
remember it ends with him becoming Robin
Hood like the whole movie is like Robin
Hood begins basically and so with this
one the same alert basically tries to do
the same thing it's like even though
that's already been done by another
movie that has any other Robin Hood
called him Rob hey Rob oh my god the
Disney one does they come right you sir
that's not in the trailer but it is yeah
hey Rob yeah just remember that so there
you go why would you do revenue if you
didn't have any new place for it to go
anything to say because a hundred
million dollars doesn't spend itself one
yeah they're just like look these kids
love Robin Hood they're running around
in their Robin Hood costumes they're
cosplaying Robin Hood
yes surgery camps are huge rests we
gotta play into this like the krob and
hood crane first I was gonna say well
cuz they'll lose the IP but then I was
immediately like no no we could
literally make a Robin Hood movie here
yes amaro I think we should legally but
just like set it in the future and space
or oh it's coming up something do
something to give it some kind of twist
or you could set yours apart from every
other Robin Hood movie yes well that
said yeah price jump right in so much to
say bang
yeah
[Music]
from the studio that combined hot actors
with archery to create a hit phenomenon
comes a movie that combines hot actors
with archery to make but also a movie
Robin hood-like a Robin buzz it must
hate it must suck to make so much money
with those Hunger Games Movies and let's
just see it all not all but a large
chunk of it just down the drain
yeah because they also did the wasn't
even called Allegiant and the virgin
they did that as well right and that did
not know that didn't even make the TV
show no it's obviously kind of weird
Hunger Games hasn't spun off yet you
would think if that was your property
you'd be like well presidents no prequel
Hunger Games was vastly diminishing
returns
sure yeah by the fourth one even
worldwide it was it was it was quickly
going downhill yeah we got it we get it
thank you next yeah and they were really
hoping that this Robin Hood was gonna do
something like he's good looking arrows
secret Hunger Games success was the
arrow he's a great personality
Taron Egerton yeah I like him yeah he's
very charismatic it's gonna be great as
Elton John I think Jamie Foxx is good in
this movie everyone's doing their best
yeah everyone is trying not it's not
their fault I will say that and honestly
Jamie Dornan who is the sheriff he's
that he's darling in this he's he's a
very good actor he's in a TV series
called the fall that's an Irish series
it's on Netflix Gillian Anderson isn't
it with him and it's great and he's good
and so every time he's in a movie I'm
like oh it's the guy from the fall is
like the Fifty Shades movies and now
it's just like he's he's getting into
worst movies is he the Taylor Kitsch
yeah he's the new Taylor kitchen like
you would be good if they put you in
anything that wasn't horrible and yet
here we go let's go Robin Hood has been
Flynn foxy feathery funny oh that Malloy
he's back with an all-new twist this
time he's played by that guy from
Kingsman that you like and nope that's
it
strap in as this Prince of Thieves takes
on the Sheriff of Nottingham play by the
current MVP of menacing bad guys ben
mendelsohn out first of all first of all
I know using a never try to out Rickman
Alan Rickman now you will lose every
time he was Chyna out Alan Rickman Alan
Rickman that Sheriff of Nottingham you
can't touch it yeah don't try to outdo
they're even doing the thing where he
promises over-the-top punishments which
is Ricky's bit in a Prince of Thieves
come on never never get in a Rickman
the idea of in acting just being really
good at one very specific thing and
someone's like we need someone who can
just menacingly yelled nonsense okay
he's good at watch bloodline if you've
never seen it it's good until it's
career circa 2019 yep my favourite role
of his is in Quigley down under I got a
very odd-looking sure you did pretty
young in that movie anyway if you're a
fan of Australian westerns make sure you
see Quigley down under let's go kiss but
Robin I'm room sorry Rob
has backup like Jamie Foxx's John who's
only called John because foreign names
are hard
yeah ever nuuma yoky up we use this TV
yeah do it means no more we use this
joke all the time yeah Jurgis like the
most it's not as trailers level joke yes
yeah judge that how you will be better
than us you can it's not us making this
job this is the movie making yeah we're
putting it out I'm just saying that is
level of humor yeah
when we can't think we need to say about
the favorite and you're just like the
most directed it that's the level of
ever so at that point you're waiting for
Friar Tuck to come out and be like be
pretty much we also saw that shot where
it where Rob shoots the arrow at John
and then it hits the plugin and the
camera like does that 180 to show you
like oh he had a board in front of them
there aren't any other shots like that
in the movie it's like one scene that
night regimes like came in and gets
directed yeah it's such a weird
stylistic choice because it's it's the
only shot like that yeah well because
and because it's like of the movie then
has no style because it just see my
scene is like that's a cool thing from
another thing we've seen lockdown for
one sequence yeah let's keep going as
backup like Jamie Foxx is John who's
only called John because foreign names
are hard yeah yeah
you've called over hippocrates yeah yeah
please no more a Friar Tuck who thinks
he's in the Mel Brooks version they
spend another mar not incident a will
Scarlett that's also here and Marion the
woman that Robin wants to spin around
with for the rest of his life
I found this very interesting which is
when you watch the movie they're
building up the entire Robin Marion
romance is building up to the big love
scene yeah like they're spinning around
the castle they're talking about how
have they loved each other and then in
the other movie it would show you that
moment of them like at least there was
not even a tasteful pan to a fireplace
they're you know just spinning around in
the castle and then he gets as we know
later a draft notice for the Crusader I
guess that's that was a choice yeah it's
like a rough Wiggum thing I saw daddy
spin with yeah it's very it's very odd I
mean they're how all their whole
relationship is very odd like it just
feels like underdeveloped sort of you
know he catches her trying to steal one
of his horses right which he then gives
her mm-hmm yeah and he's sort of like
well if you would just asked I would
have given it to you anyway and then she
gets to live in it Scott and then they
just like fall in love immediately and
I'll take it there's like an interesting
story maybe there but like he catches
this lady robbing from him he's like
this spoiled rich kid and maybe if you
just stick with that and just stick with
that don't do the crusade like dude the
whole just class thing with em and he
gets caught up with these thieves
because of her and his dad's like oh
don't throw away over a girl or whatever
I don't reckon maybe that's cool that's
a new tape well that's different from
prints a big what they do is just Prince
of Thieves yeah and it's like at least
that would be that's not Prince of
Thieves
like Robin of Loxley in that one doesn't
start off as like a selfish jerk and so
that's a different play on raised I was
kind that's row so because he's like it
doesn't start with the thief you know so
forget what you know and so I was like
okay I'll be oh nope it's not it's just
okay with me all right let's go this
life
No there are a ton of merry men that
never end up in the movies guys there's
Gilbert white hands cesarean where my
Reynold Greenleaf fans that come on
anybody ooh da lolly I'm only journey to
an all new Nottingham said in the
Nordstrom Rack era of England where
crossbows are rapid-fire machine gun
it's got old and archers sneak around
like SEAL Team six
but after you forget what you think it's
just it looks dumb like so many people
with long bows just one currently like
they're doing they're doing like the
check your six like the SEAL team you
know movements yeah I like to check your
corners and but if there was a guy
behind you you did before you could turn
around and fire an arrow that's for
close quarters confident sense someone
throw this out there at the time of the
Crusades these cities not horrible ruins
yeah your saints made them horrible
rooms remember they dropped ordnance
yeah gave them their coordinates to
likes catapults and stuff so it's just
no constant like I'm not saying it has
to be like vividly historically accurate
no I just got a look possible I'm gonna
say this if you're gonna take a that big
of a home run where you're like complete
alternate history everything's kind of a
combination between his like the past
and fantasy and modern you know like
Nordstrom Rack slim-fitting tux or
whatever where everyone's walking around
in their finest blue blazer plus the
weird SEAL Team six stuff if you're
gonna take swings that big you've got to
make it an entertaining movie like one
that you're like you know what it was
weird but super fine so consistent
moment yeah I feel like it's all
happening in one reality whereas this
does not at all yeah it was like it's
sometimes it's in the Middle Ages
sometimes it's like the 1800s if this is
last week oh boy let's go thanks but
after you forget what
you think you know forget what you think
you know yeah be better I said that
there's plenty of stuff that you already
knew from the other Robin Hood's like
Robin having a cool black friend Robin
being a disgraced Lord the baddie having
a wacky sidekick
and a creepy religious figure lurking in
the background we would have so did you
tell me to forget what I know because
you already knew what I know and knew
you didn't have anything new because
you've just replaced what I knew with a
version of what I already knew that I'd
like to forget you know thank you
first of all I'll say as long as it's
within my power and our head writer
isn't here to tell me I can't do it I
will always put clips from Robin Hood
men in tights and then I'd also just
realized I think the guy that does the
Andre the Giant obey probably has a
decent lawsuit with the wanted posters
in the house well it's yeah it's this
movie is rooted into that this movie you
can tell was written and conceived of in
about 1000 8 2009 in an urban outfitters
but just the idea of the Occupy Wall
Street was obviously behind when this
was developed the lengths to which this
project went through development is very
obvious will Scarlett especially have a
very like they're community organizers
you know it's varied that that's a very
modern sort of take on it for sure
yeah no boy who's just not yeah it
doesn't work there she is she's great
you changed it to latrine it used to
make it house let's just watch men in
tights yeah so did you tell me to forget
what I know because you already knew
what I know and knew you didn't have
anything new because you've just
replaced what I knew with a version of
what I already knew that I'd like to
forget you know but this is not just a
boring copy of every Robin Hood movie
you see it's all just a history of every
bad man you see
the way this Robin Hood is also a rich
young man that trained in a distant land
who returned home to fight injustice as
a masked vigilante he helps his social
activist girlfriend protect the slums
it's a secret identity speedbump and his
associates in the same relation to rise
up against a villain and was the good
guy dating his ass even steal from CW's
arrow we still find arrows and see solid
evidence the hood was there and that's a
show that was already about an orchard
that was dealing for Batman Lord Loxley
you have failed this franchise
pazzo Tate you don't you don't not know
that you're doing that looks two-faced
he's clearly a vote to face Dark Knight
in that scene love you're either a hero
are young enough to die he's literally a
hero who then does not die and lose to
see himself become the villain it's it's
incredibly late they definitely knew but
you also have to wonder like are they
hoping that it's subtle enough that
audiences won't realize they're being
remanded to an actual two-face we have
to change it enough so people don't
realize we're ripping it off and we're
just like suggesting it it's like a
thing they liked it they don't know but
if you make it this blatant everybody's
just like oh it's like it's like Batman
the only thing they didn't do is have
the Sheriff of Nottingham gets punched
in the throat and haven't come out like
[Music]
it's it's very late I got the
slim-fitting everything when I remember
like when she said Locksley is the
disguise I think I just went uh it was a
very small screening room it was very
uncomfortable
but luckily Roth I think did the same
thing Swede saw it together just like
why it was immediately followed by a
line she literally goes if not you who
if not now when it's like give up did
they just give up on the writing and the
they got to like page 100 and I can
whatever is like the the actual
explanation is probably like the
producers just gives a like more like a
superhero movie more like a superhero
movie every new draft that came in and
eventually the writers were just like
well I'll just rewrite a famous
superhero movie and then the producer
were like exactly this guy that's really
why I pushed for us to do an honest
trailer for this it's not even really
for the views it's almost for posterity
to be preserved for posterity lest
anyone actually never know that this
happened yeah I mean I guess if that was
the pitch like what if Robin Hood but
superhero movie oh yeah right no you're
absolutely every public domain character
no you're totally right yeah yeah I had
even almost tapped out at this point
because I stopped taking notes just like
forget kind of the moment that like
these guys in if you're gonna have okay
so you're writing a movie about an
archer and you're like how can we make
sure that it's believable that he's
taking down all these dudes and stuff
like that maybe your city guards and
your bad guy Knights are just like dudes
without helmets just like in leather
armor or something so those are just two
dicks or something so maybe okay arrows
taking them down but these guys are
straight-up tanks like they're wearing
they're just wearing sheets of hyerin
you're gonna make a bow and arrow look
like you know you could take out a city
with my yeah you have to do that doesn't
work any other way but it looks stupid
yes so at that point I don't like the
moment I saw him put an arrow through
like a six-inch piece of plate metal on
a guy's forehead and I was like I'm good
Batman II and I was like okay let me
take a look oh god it is theirs I'll
tell you at the end of starring because
we addressed it I'll tell you what I was
done with the movie but it was slightly
before Batman but okay I was like after
the starring the tag immediately tag is
about the beginning of the movie no no
no after that was when I was dead let's
fail this franchise so take aim with
this wannabe franchise starter that
missed the target by creating a cool
fantasy world and filling it with a
boring story resulting in one of the
biggest swathes of 2018 which probably
pumped the brakes on the other six Robin
Hood movies also in development wait
seven Margot Robbie's Maid Marian what
the hexa Prince of Aragon Robin Hood
2058 okay I would totally watch Robin
Hood came in because we were we had
another ending and actually during the
read-through
we were just reading through the article
and Daniel Radford was in writing
something else and she says that no it
was like I don't watch Robin Hood 24
like mess last night I would I would
also write Java 222 yeah what I what I
used to do scripting I'll make this
quick when a series Chris there was one
that was called I guess I say Neverland
and it was Peter Pan 20:58
and it was just like in this future and
Captain Hook was a drug dealer and like
they were all like these young hackers
like Peter the Lost Boys and like kind
of stupid but also kind of cool I'll
watch that yeah this would have been way
better if it was like cyberpunk
yeah I also love Kiev 2058 being a
distant far-flung future at this point
like in me before you know it
yeah be 2050 everybody's Jordans will
look a little different that's about it
okay okay alright starring let's do this
20:58 okay i would totally watch Robin
Hood 2058 story bro in arrows don't cost
you of course add two shades of faith
incredibly clever and fun Alex Agassi of
course that just goes to shades of face
almost like a thought exercise I just
need to get some random words out and it
worked
yeah look biggest laugh in the room it
goes in sometimes the dumbest one
apparently starring it it is sometimes
like highbrow political humor or Alan
Rickman friar fast and Robin Hood's mask
falling off
Pop's the Kevin Orr editor here yeah
oh sorry good great it wasn't hard Robin
Hood man it bites alright pause that
moment it was one of the masks falling
off it's the Wonder there Robert the red
they have this big Treasury robbery you
think it's their big bold move and he
jumps out the window and lands in the
cart in the racing way and his mask has
fallen down and they're they're in the
cart and he's talking to James people
everywhere there's a crowd of people on
the streets he's in the back of the cart
talking to Jamie this is halfway through
the movie talking to Jamie Foxx
everybody's guards see them the
townspeople see them and yet throughout
the rest of the film
everyone's like who is the hood you know
it's Robin Hood and I'm just like I know
that there's a certain amount that
suspension of disbelief that you have to
give any superhero movie if I saw Bruce
Wayne
in the bat suit without a cow in the
Batmobile with Alfred his public Butler
I might think that maybe Batman is Bruce
Wayne yeah it's there's just no like
there was no mask work attention nobody
was like hey you got to put your mask on
I can see who you are I was just like
selling paint
we paid five million dollars for it and
also you know on that note speaking of
his Alfred his sidekick slash mentor
slash the guy that's like putting this
whole thing together
the only more in the city in the country
in a country that is at war with with
him with his country he's the only only
guy he's not wearing a mask he and his
wife he's not like he's hiding and locks
like he's public this public front is
his service I am his manservant and yet
he's constantly seen driving the hood
around like you think maybe there's some
connection there it's also he arrives it
he's from where the Crusades are in the
Middle East
yes he's part of the Crusades he sneaks
ystos away on Robins boat to come to
England
for the first time it wasn't easy to go
back and forth he lands knowing
everything about English society he's
got all these plans for how they're
gonna get the share but he wouldn't know
what a sheriff was not from there he was
doing some reading
no curled up like Missy's are stoic and
then they'll and he's like all right I
got a plan I know jack here's what you
gotta do you gotta go rob that Treasury
it's over there take a left you just
gonna take down the card then she runs
on money the church run like the movie
doesn't know any information about
England how do you know again cool
opportunity to do something new if like
in the Crusades he meets this dude who's
like a higher-up
yeah you know because as far as we know
he's just a grunt and him and his son
are serving in the war right but if it's
like oh no he's like this like high up
dude that's like I want to bring a stop
to all of this right if they'd euro
Morris let's do it right even if he
couldn't you could have done a version
of it where he gets to Robin in the
Middle East is like let's go back to
England I've got a plan and then it
makes sense this way it's just like oh
you just lucked out and got the one more
in all of Jordan who knows exactly how
the feudal system is set up yeah good
thing I plucked this guy out of
Mogadishu with the rest of my [ __ ] down
teams all the crusade stuff is so
powerfully stupid we put it in there at
the end yeah let's do it
Robin Hood man it bites you know I've
done this movie is we didn't even
mention how Robin answers the door to
his own giant castle to get a draft
notice for the Crusades
gilad I mean you know when you weren't
getting drafted in the Crusades we you
would go yourself lay with Knights set
Lords plundered themselves you the
church wouldn't want to send you other
cousin have to pay for you to go it's
very expensive that's where they
recruited rich people to go so there's
no way he would be recruited also the
whole movie has the Cardinal like the
sheriff's working for the Cardinal which
makes no sense that's different like the
Cardinals of the Church of the sheriff
was the work so the king is like oh he's
like a cop it would be like if you had a
and there was a small town and the
police officer worked for the priest but
lon money runs the show the guy that
came from the Crusades told me so it's
just mad every new scene is like one
more just wildly stupid thing because of
your hatred of the because that was one
of the first notes you you sent while I
was putting this trap together was like
why is he opening his own door yeah yeah
I started looking at that more and I was
like where is anyone nobody he doesn't
have any people working in his cuz
there's no sir I don't think you see a
single servant throughout the entire
movie there's that one see where he
comes into this stable while she's
stealing the horse and they have
background and others going like it was
a you know lived in area but that's it
otherwise it's all empty Hall he's
cleaning that ball plays himself you
think so yeah I mean it's like I don't
know it's like a con man who like is
like yeah this is my house
yeah people are aware whatever it is
traveling for the first few scenes
you're kind of waiting for like his dad
or his my like he doesn't seem like he's
the Lord running that old castle yes
running the whole castle him setting the
door to the horses people the red
Locksley Manor seems a lot of work how
did I get how are they like holes in the
roof was there a bad is there a battle
at Locksley manor is back and it's just
different red grass tried for years it's
wrecked like there are castles and ruins
that are in better shape now but that's
the other thing too is that if if his
castle had been taken away it would have
been given to somebody even get a
sheriff of Lebanon or something no it
was seized yeah it's just sitting empty
like that would be a lot of money you're
just leaving on the table that you'd be
at work in their suits you want them to
pay you taxes you don't just want it to
sit empty I think it was seized and
moved to the Crusades and then they
moved it back right before he got you
[Music]
I'm not a medieval scholar these are
just obvious things well by this movie
standards line you are yeah yeah anybody
oh man so the very first scene in the
church when we meet Friar Tuck he's
taking confession which friars don't do
that's priest they just bring friars
drink wine yeah they make beer they
don't take another trailer but yes so
they had they could not resist doing the
your one good Friar Tuck again I was
amazed at the movie cuz the movie ends
again they at the end they pull a Robin
Hood begins and him and his now merry
men are like to the forest
yeah and I'm amazed that they weren't
like Sherwood that's a good place I was
waiting for us shall we go this next
would seems good sire it's called but
they do they try a weird I'm gonna I'm
gonna spoil the intimate yeah it's fine
they do this weird sleight of hand where
the whole movie they're like this is the
Sheriff of Nottingham and at the end
they're like he wasn't the real Sheriff
of Nottingham this is the real it's too
late I just saw that someone thought
that was a clever twist which aru so he
can kill the bad guy in the next movie
that's so dumb yes we're not gonna go
for that
it's a yeah I did my big thing again was
like you go out of your way to make a
cool weird fantasy world and you just
fill it with with nothing like the Guy
Ritchie King Arthur is dumb but at least
like they took their big swing and until
the third act where it just turned into
a video game boss fight yeah or the big
evil version of Jude Law yes Jude Law is
just like don't touch the or sky beam a
little then I was just like I don't know
that I like this but at least it's just
crazy and by consistently crazy
I was bored a lot during Robin Hood I
was not bored a laughter game I was I
was engaged in thinking that it was
stupid but I was engaged
yeah yeah it was bad yeah but this is uh
they're both bad I'm gonna go home and
watch where you watch Prince of Thieves
there you go you know what pretty good
it's up not bad do you have any deleted
season we do we do story ha ha not so
sterling Archer praise a JB of Foxley
hand fool of a tuck BOGO that begins the
Crusades Brad comes back I'm going to
Canada and that's the movie there you go
all the parts of the movie you need to
worry about I think we got every every
interesting moment in there again this
is really for posterity
yeah this is so that people know that we
were the the Watchers on the watchtower
we are the Watchers on the wall our
watch has ended this is gonna be one of
those like in ten years will people
remember there was the Russell Crowe
Robin Hood and then the Taron Egerton
one or oh that just meld totally
together in people's mind I think so
yeah no no remember that's bad
Ott's experiment well there's gonna be
another one in eight to ten years so
probably yeah agree they can just keep
making how are they just they're just
gonna keep cranking through that I still
want to watch Robin Hood 2058 yeah yeah
me too yeah it's gonna be good get going
guys let us know in the comments which
Robin Hood spin-off you are most excited
for next week next week next week is
another franchise hmm that's not good I
don't actually know what this is are you
going figure out people guess because we
make it too easy and now nobody will
know if they got it right yeah it's
another yeah it's bad right here next
week see you later bye guys
you